The Human
Condition is no small
picnic we are uniquely aware which is
both our blessing and our curse we have
the mental capacity as Ernest Becker
said to ponder the infinite seemingly
capable of anything yet we're housed in
these heart pumping breath gasping
decaying bodies we are gods and we are
worms and so there there is a faint
disqui that haunts our dreams even our
greatest ecstasies are tinged by a bit
of Sadness by a bit of turmoil by the
existential grief and paralyzing
realization that all is transient and
that one day we will
die and how to make sense and how to
assimilate and how to make peace with
the disqui so that we may function with
some kind of equinity in the face of
such a burden upon the
psyche Ernest Becker said that the full
realization of The Human Experience is
one in which the only response is full
and open
psychosis this is the reason why we are
in an epic epidemic mental health
situation in the world today because we
have materially secured our needs which
has only deepened the wounds and needs
of our psyches which cannot be a swashed
or accommodated into personal
Extinction you have emerged out of
nothing to have a name consciousness of
self deep inner feeling and excruciating
inner yearning for life and
self-expression and with all this yet to
die it's [__] difficult right we know
we are Gods we make manifest and
engender our imagination we exteriorize
our creativity we instantiate the
renderings of mind the man-made world is
the condensation of human imagination
said Terence McKenna look at us dazzling
Alchemists right the coral reef like
animal the extruder of technological
material right we take in matter of low
organization we put it through the
filters of the human mind and we
extrude magnificent renderings of our
inner landscape made manifest outside
we turn our insides out this is who we
are this is what we are how can we
simultaneously wither away age and
die we are the species that can sing the
songs that orchestrate the universe and
we are the species that has to take a
[__] once a day sitting on a [__]
toilet surrendering our dignity to
[__]
[Music]
waste okay so what to do what to do what
to do right we're in a festival a desert
landscape a demolition derby of reality
constructs colliding on a parched void
as Eric Davis once described Burning Man
We Are beholding The Human Condition we
get to explore the maze with 18 rooms
inside that head which is a metaphor for
our own heads so we get to go inside our
own minds and clean that [__] out and
clean the gun look out we get to see our
lenses of perception right there they
are and we see with those lenses and we
see through those lenses but we don't
see the lenses
themselves unless we are cracked open
unless we uh are [__] slapped by awe a
moment of such revery and enthralment
that you bump up a level and all of a
sudden the lenses you see through and
with you actually see and now that I'm
seeing the lenses I'm I'm seeing how
they inform my world my lenses determine
what I
see I don't see the world as it is I see
it as I am or rather I see it through my
lenses so can I dispense of those lenses
can I relinquish those lenses can I
smash those lenses can I upgrade those
lenses can I lease a new pair of lenses
can I summon new lenses with an app on
my [__] iPhone the point being I've
seen another place to plant my feet
there is another way to see the world
there is another way to operate there is
another way to give our gifts there is
another way to make a
[Music]
contribution and perhaps this is the
most noble the no the most noble of
responses to our
situation we may be we may be flawed
stumbling primates but when we work
together we are primates that can fly
and manifest art and engender their
imaginations and reprogram biology and
reverse engineer matter and engender of
seventh Kingdom of Life Kevin Kelly's
technium and this capacity to imagine to
conceive to design architect and create
in combination with our modest looking
thumbs as Kur said was sufficient to
create a secondary force of evolution
made manifest by our tools and
Technologies and artists
stre and it will continue dare I say I
hope until the entire universe is at our
fingertips for as alen Harington said we
must never forget we are cosmic
revolutionaries not stes conscripted to
advance the natural order that kills
everyone so let us get [__] to it let
us get to
it
[Music]
nice one dude